[Music]
day 4 life is beautiful and day in vegas
are set with festivals on schedule scams
are on the rise
bianca holman explains how to avoid
being taken advantage of
summer is here celebrations are planned
and many are excited to attend music
festivals
the better business bureau has a warning
criminals are cashing in on phony
tickets and fake events
this is how the agency says the scam
works first you see an amazing deal on a
ticket in your area through a social
media post that has a link
the event may promise live music all you
can eat food or specials on beer and
wine
the link takes you to a website that
looks professional so you use your
credit card to buy the ticket and mark
your calendar
the bvb has received numerous reports
from people about non-existent tickets
events that never happened were
postponed
or customers that never got a refund now
a criminal has your money
picture but here's how to spot a fake
first
research be sure the advertise festival
matches the website
check for working contact information
email and phone number
keep an eye out for prices that are too
good to be true
and finally avoid tickets sold on
craigslist facebook marketplace or free
online listings
bianca holman 8 news now